lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
explorar la noción de espacio muestral y
esta noción es muy sencilla por ejemplo
si tienes un experimento que involucra
algo aleatorio que tiene que ver con la
probabilidad entonces el espacio
muestral es el conjunto de todos los
posibles resultados de ese experimento
por ejemplo si tenemos un experimento
muy sencillo cómo tirar un volado volado
tenemos dos posibilidades podemos
obtener aguilar o podemos obtener sol
entonces estos son nuestros posibles
resultados y este es nuestro espacio
muestral y es muy útil porque por
ejemplo si estos fueran resultados x
probables y nos quisiéramos preguntar
cuál es la probabilidad de sacar sol en
el próximo volado lo único que tenemos
que hacer es ver nuestro espacio
muestral y decir ok de los dos posibles
resultados 1
ellos hace que saquemos sol en el volado
entonces la probabilidad es 1 entre 2 y
listo e incluso si no todos los
resultados son x probables podemos
construir la función de densidad de
probabilidad o la función de
distribución por lo menos ya tenemos el
espacio muestral ya lo único que nos
falta es saber cuál es la probabilidad
de cada uno de los posibles resultados
ahora generalmente cuando las personas
se ponen a hablar acerca del espacio
muestral es cuando es más sutil qué
sucede cuando los posibles resultados si
son x probables como sucede con los
volados porque entonces podemos sacar la
probabilidad de cualquier evento a
partir del espacio muestral lo único que
tenemos que hacer es contar cuántos de
los posibles resultados hacen que suceda
el evento y bueno este es un espacio
muestral muy sencillo ahora lo que vamos
a hacer es ver un espacio muestral un
poco más complicado aunque entonces
vamos a poner
esto a un lado digamos más bien que
vamos a comprar un bote de helado de
postre ahora en la heladería hay tres
tipos de sabores que nos gustan mucho
pero también hay tres tipos de tamaño de
bote de helado entonces la cosa que
tenemos que escoger varía en dos
sentidos distintos déjame lo escribo va
a quedar mucho más quedaron muy pronto
tenemos distintos tipos de sabores
aunque por aquí voy a escribir los
sabores
moritz
el helado puede ser de chocolate o puede
ser sabor a fresa o puede ser de un
clásico vainilla y los botes de helado
vienen en tres tamaños distintos aunque
hoy vamos a poner por aquí los tamaños
está en años los cuales son chico
mediano
o grande y digamos que en esta heladería
cada uno de estos sabores viene en todos
los tamaños o también podríamos decir
que para cada uno de los tamaños tenemos
estos tres sabores y ahora cómo
construyes el espacio muestral por
ejemplo qué pasaría si yo me tapo los
ojos
entro a la heladería y sin poder ver
absolutamente nada señaló con mis dedos
algún helado mis dedos obviamente no
pueden distinguir ni el sabor ni el
tamaño del helado pero de esa forma
aleatoria escojo un helado donde pues el
helado tiene un sabor y un tamaño aunque
entonces cuáles son todos los posibles
resultados de este experimento cuál es
mi espacio muestral bueno hay que notar
que estos posibles resultados están
definidos por un sabor y un tamaño y hay
muchas formas de pensar en esto una de
ellas es hacer un árbol por ejemplo
puedo decir yo voy a escoger o un helado
de chocolate
chocolate o voy a escoger un helado de
fresa fresa
o un helado de vainilla vainilla
y para cada uno de estos sabores de
helado puedo escoger qué sea un bote
chico mediano o grande y lo mismo para
el helado sabor fresa puede ser chico y
por cierto aquí este de aquí es un
helado de chocolate chico y esto de aquí
es un helado de chocolate mediano y un
helado de chocolate grande y aquí
tenemos un helado de fresa chico un
helado de fresa mediano o un helado de
fresa grande o también podemos tener un
helado de vainilla chico un helado de
vainilla mediano o un helado de vainilla
grande y como podemos ver tenemos nueve
opciones distintas aquí hay otra vez
este de aquí es un helado de chocolate
mediano y por ejemplo este de acá es un
helado de vainilla grande y también lo
pudimos haber hecho al revés aunque
también podríamos haber escogido primero
si es un helado chico
mediano o grande y después para cada uno
de estos tamaños tenemos tres opciones
de sabor y voy a utilizar únicamente las
iniciales de los sabores ok entonces si
escogimos un helado chico puede ser de
chocolate de fresa o de vainilla
ok aquí cuando pongo un ace con rosa nos
estamos refiriendo al sabor chocolate y
la cee con verde al tamaño chico pero
bueno si escogimos un helado mediano
puede ser sabor chocolate fresa o
vainilla o también podemos tener un
helado grande de chocolate de fresa o de
vainilla cuando estábamos en este árbol
nos fijamos en esta opción que era un
helado de chocolate mediano y si lo
buscamos en este otro árbol a ver el
lado mediano de chocolate que está por
aquí entonces estas dos opciones son
exactamente la misma nunca y son un
helado de chocolate mediano
es que puedes usar cualquiera de estos
árboles para pensar en los nueve
posibles resultados del experimento o
también podrías hacer una tabla para
hacer la tabla podemos empezar
escribiendo los sabores por aquí tenemos
el chocolate
chocolate luego la fresa aunque sabes
que mejor nada más voy a poner las
iniciales de chocolate fresa y vainilla
y por acá vamos a escribir los tamaños
que podemos tener un bote de helado
chico mediano o grande y vamos a poner
la cuadrícula
y como puedes observar esta tabla tiene
nueve cuadros que son los nueve posibles
resultados y bueno esto es simplemente
otra forma de hacerlo y que tenemos aquí
pues tenemos un chocolate chico
chocolate chico y por acá tenemos un
helado de fresa chico fresa chico y
bueno todo lo que esté en este renglón
va a ser un helado chico ok chico y
bueno en este último cuadro es un helado
de vainilla chico vainilla y en este
renglón vamos a tener puros helados
medianos aunque hay el lado mediano de
chocolate mediano de fresa mediano de
vainilla y por aquí puros helados
grandes el lado grande de chocolate
grande de fresa y grande de vainilla ok
en esta tabla tenemos nueve espacios que
son los nueve posibles resultados
y esto es simplemente otra forma de
pensar en todos los resultados posibles
cuando los helados únicamente varían en
sabor y tamaño ok pero bueno hay otra
forma de hacerlo muy común que es
simplemente hacer una lista de todos los
posibles resultados aunque y lo vamos a
hacer aquí y para hacer esto voy a poner
por aquí una columna de sabores
bores y al lado una columna de tamaños
años
y otra vez únicamente voy a utilizar las
iniciales que podemos tener tres tipos
de helados de chocolate
podemos tener chocolate chico chocolate
mediano y chocolate grande que tenemos
aquí el chocolate chico el chocolate
mediano y el chocolate grande
y luego tenemos tres tipos de helado de
fresa ok tenemos fresa chica fresa
mediana y fresa grande fresa chica fresa
mediana fresa grande y tenemos tres
tipos de helados de vainilla tenemos
helado de vainilla chico el lado de
vainilla mediano y el lado de vainilla
grande ok entonces en total tenemos
nueve botes de helados distintos nueve
posibles resultados ahora el espacio
muestral no te dice nada acerca de las
probabilidades no te dice si todos estos
resultados son equiparables lo único que
te dice el espacio muestral es que
puedes obtener de resultado ahora si tu
experimento fuera de tal forma que todos
sus posibles resultados tienen la misma
probabilidad o sea son equipo probable
entonces el espacio muestral te dice
muchísimo
super útil y es muy fácil calcular la
probabilidad de cualquier evento
por ejemplo si dijéramos que tenemos la
misma probabilidad de escoger cualquiera
de estos posibles resultados entonces es
súper sencillo calcular la probabilidad
de por ejemplo escoger un helado que sea
chico o de chocolate y lo que podemos
hacer es contar cuántos de estos
posibles resultados satisfacen con esa
condición y luego dividirlo entre el
número total de resultados o sea
dividirlo entre 9 y listo
ahí está la probabilidad no lo vamos a
hacer ahorita lo vamos a hacer en un
vídeo próximamente sin embargo eso te
puede dar una idea de por qué nos
importan estas cosas como los espacios
muestrales ok especialmente estos
espacios muestrales que tienen dos
categorías que varían en dos direcciones
distintas y también hay otros espacios
muestrales que tienen más categorías
sobre las cuales varían
este tipo de espacios muestrales se
llaman espacios muestrales compuestos
aunque como este espacio de aquí este es
un espacio muestral compuesto porque
tiene dos categorías sobre las cuales
varía a diferencia de este espacio
muestral donde varía en una sola
dirección o es águila o el sol y ya aquí
puede variar el sabor o el tamaño y por
eso es un espacio muestral compuesto